[Applause]
i texted sandler um
and he sent me three texts and i'm
wondering
um i need you to decode them
so we're gonna play what is sandler
saying okay
all right
treading water in a pool
well i think that
means that we lived in this apartment
like a really bad apartment in north
hollywood and every day adam would to i
guess is what he thought exercise was
because he wanted to be in good shape
that he would tread water in the pool
for long amounts of time and be like
this is good for your abs and he would
just sit there like treading water
but for like really low and and then i
remember uh
uh uh you know i obviously would never
do it the next text he sent me says
never worked out together never no i
never worked out ever
okay and then the next 10 uh text says
suntan
bed burned tush
so then adam would go get like he would
go like a tanning booth and so he went
to a tanning booth and then one day like
you should get a tan get a tan i'm like
oh maybe i maybe i should get a tan so i
did it i don't know what i did wrong
so i'm in there in my underwear i don't
know if i positioned things wrong i was
sweating too much but i feel like the
tandy booth like
maybe my sweat boiled and just burned my
my butt
um well okay so your book there's a
stain on this book i was with my
daughters we were in hawaii and a
cockroach ran into the room and my
daughter started screaming so i grabbed
your book and just started killing it
with the book i thought maybe you were
either going to be
mad or think it was all sad that's what
it's there for murder
i also like literally i
i i really had a hard time sort of
choosing which
chapter i loved the most um but i think
it has to be the david letterman and
this conversation with him was like
something i had never heard
first of all we all wanted to be like
him we were all inspired by how
groundbreaking he was i went to a taping
of his show within the first three
months when i was a kid but now that
he's not doing the show
you know he's a little more available to
talk to people and tell us how he's
doing what his life is like and then we
get a chance to uh
to thank him at the end of the interview
i said to him i just want you to know
that like you changed so many of our
lives and you inspired us so much and he
said
and he said that's right judd there'd be
no comedy without me
[Music]
you